Joe beiden also zu Besuch jetzt in Polen
nach seinem Abstecher in Kiel von bei
mir im Studio ist jetzt Andreas
heinemann-grüder von BIC das ist der
Bonn International Center of conflict
studies Herr Heinemann grüder der Besuch
von Joe Biden gestern in Kiew hat er
Putin heute ein bisschen aus ihrer Sicht
die Show gestohlen oder
beeindruckt einen russischen Präsidenten
so etwas nicht mehr das ist natürlich
ein Kampf der Bilder also wer dominiert
sozusagen die Fernsehschirme und beiden
es tut ihm jetzt vorweg vorweg gekommen
insofern hat er 24 Stunden lang
sozusagen die Fernseher global
beherrscht und ähm
putin ist aber oft die Besuch von beiden
überhaupt nicht eingegangen das fand ich
auch interessant alle dachten er würde
seine Rede jetzt beim über Nacht noch
umschreiben müssen das war nicht der
Fall wir kommen gleich noch mal auf die
Rede von Vladimir Putin etwas
ausführlicher zu sprechen aber bleiben
wir noch mal bei Joe beiden der ist ja
jetzt in Polen eingetroffen wird heute
dort so wird ja auch angekündigt vom
weißen Haus aber von mehreren US-Medien
auch noch eine bedeutende Rede heute
Nachmittag halten was kann der denn
überhaupt noch versprechen also
interessant finde ich wird der Vergleich
zwischen der Rede die er vor einem Jahr
in Warschau gehalten hat wo er letztlich
ja den Regimewechsel in Moskau als
Voraussetzung für einen Friedensschluss
genannt hat da musste er danach wieder
erheblich zurückrudern es wird also
jetzt interessant was er letztlich als
die rote Linie der USA oder des Westens
insgesamt formuliert das heißt nicht nur
keine Niederlage der Ukraine sondern
möglicherweise eben auch ein Sieg über
die russischen Truppen und was das
letztlich heißt kann man hoffen dass da
jetzt das politische Ziel dieses der
westlichen Unterstützung für die Ukraine
ausgesprochen wird das ist ja bis heute
nicht so ganz eindeutig worauf man sich
da einstellt aber sie sind ja auch
konfliktforscher das bürgt ja wenn Joe
Beine sich weit aus dem Fenster lehnt
heute auch sagt beispielsweise gr ist
eines der
Minimalziele sozusagen für die Ukraine
das bedeutet ja enormes
Konfliktpotenzial was da auf uns zukommt
ich glaube man muss den Krieg vom Ende
her denken man muss letztlich hier sich
vorstellen wie könnte der Krieg enden
und was werden eigentlich die
Bedingungen die Ausgangsbedingungen um
überhaupt an einem diplomatischen
Prozess eintreten zu können das heißt
auf der einen Seite sehen wir dass die
Chinesen jetzt hat seinen
friedensschüler ausstrecken sagen
Waffenstillstand keine Waffenlieferungen
andererseits aber auch territuale
Integrität der Ukraine möglicherweise
werden dich Chinesen auch eine
Resolution für den UN-Sicherheitsrat
vorbereiten dazu muss der Westen sich
jetzt auch Verhalten und sagen
unterstützen wir die Chinesen oder
finden wir sozusagen eine gemeinsame
Position mit den Chinesen oder sehen wir
die Chinesen nur als Bündnispartner von
Russland an das steht auf der
Tagesordnung und wird meines Erachtens
auch die nächsten Wochen wenn ich Monate
beschäftigen welche Rolle spielen wenn
ich mir das einfach mal ang ucke den
gestrigen und den heutigen Tag das ganze
findet statt Moskau Kiew Washington
welche Rolle spielen wir Europäer denn
eigentlich noch haben wir überhaupt noch
was mit zu reden
bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
ist ja schon auch deutlich geworden dass
die gesamtunterstützung jetzt nicht nur
von den USA abhängig ist was lange Zeit
der Fall war also das zumindest die USA
und Großbritannien auch bei den
Waffenlieferungen die entscheidende
Rolle gespielt haben da ist jetzt
nachdem auch in Deutschland sozusagen
die Blockade gegen Panzerlieferungen
überwunden wurde doch eine einheitliche
Front da und insofern denke ich dass die
Europäer mit den anderen NATO Staaten
bei der Beschaffung von Waffen bei der
sozusagen gemeinsamen Abstimmung der
Rüstungsproduktion auch wie man die
Logistik miteinander abstimmt das ist
alles nicht nur bilateral stattfindet
also da spielen die Europäer eine sehr
zentrale Rolle dass das Miteinander auch
über einen sehr langen Zeitraum
abgestimmt wird
sprechen Waffenlieferungen an kann es
sein dass du bei sich heute auch noch
ganz konkret zu Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine äußern wird Kampfpanzer sind ja
auf dem Weg ich habe gerade gelesen ich
glaube 90 Kampfpanzer der USA sind in
Europa jetzt schon eingetroffen für die
Ukraine aber wie sieht's denn aus mit
Kampfjets beispielsweise oder mit Waffen
mit sehr viel weiterer Reichweite
beispielsweise 300 km und mehr hatte
geschossen
die Ukraine haben mehrmals
russisches Territorium auch angegriffen
also innerhalb auch des Kernlandes von
Russland aber auch die Krim meines
Erachtens nicht mit Zustimmung der USA
das heißt die USA nach wie vor die
Position der Krieg soll auf ukrainischem
aber nicht auf russisches Territorium
getragen werden und insofern erwarte ich
nicht von beiden dass er jetzt eine
Ankündigung macht die Ukraine ermutigt
sozusagen den Krieg auf jenseits der am
völkerrechtlich anerkannten Grenze
durchzuführen ein Streitpunkt wird auf
der anderen Seite auch sein was jetzt
schon in München sichtbar wurde sträume
mit Munition Phosphorbomben wo die NATO
deutlich sagt diese Art von Waffen die
bei uns geächtet sind werden die Ukraine
nicht liefern
selbst wenn es man Vorteil wäre in dem
Straßenkampf gegen so Gruppen wie Wagner
wo die Ukraine ja auch hohe
personalverluste haben aber das ist
Grenzen dessen gibt was der Westen der
Ukraine auch an Waffen liefert die rote
Linie kein Krieg auf Russisch und
Territorium wird meines Erachtens
gehalten ja es waren also Ausschnitte
Ausschnitte aus Putins Rede zur Lage der
Nation die heute morgen gehalten hat bei
mir im Studio noch Andreas
heinemann-grüter vom bicci hier in Bonn
das Bond International Center of
conflict studies was war denn das
auffällige für Sie bei der Rede hat
Putin wir haben es ja eben noch mal
gehört zum kurzen Ausschnitt hat ja
eigentlich alle bedient ne ja hat auf
der einen Seite das Militär bedient der
hat die Hinterbliebenen bediente die
jetzt sozusagen oder die Opfer dieses
Krieges er hatte die einfachen Menschen
auf der Straße bedienen indem er da auch
versprochen hat Stabilität und so weiter
an jemanden ausgelassen oder fehlte
ihnen was
ich finde den interessant an der Rede
dass er eine neue Agenda gesetzt hat er
hat angefangen damit das eigentlich der
Krieg ein Kulturkampf gegen den Westen
ist gar nicht mehr primär
Sicherheitsbedrohung sondern dass der
Westen immer Russland zerstören wollte
und dass der Westen die gradiert ist
kulturell verfallen Untergang des
Abendlandes und Russland eigentlich der
Bewahrer der christlichen Kultur ist
also insofern ein Themenwechsel hin zu
einem Kulturkampf der eigentlich in der
Ukraine ausgetragen wurde das zweite er
spricht überhaupt nicht über
Kriegsfolgen sondern sagt wir sind aus
den Sanktionen erfolgreich
hervorgegangen die Wirtschaft steht
prima da wir orientieren uns von Europa
dem Westen hin nach Südostasien
vielleicht ist es der entscheidende Push
sozusagen für die russische Wirtschaft
sich auch von der Ressourcen
Abhängigkeit hin zu Technologien zu
entwickeln das heißt der Krieg ist
eigentlich eine Chance für uns und das
weitere dass er sehr zur patriotischen
Einheit aufruft und sagt na ja die
westlich orientierten Oligarchen die
werden ja jetzt auch mit ihren Olli
Yachten in Nizza und Monaco bestraft
seht doch keine Kapitalflucht mehr ihr
seid im Westen nicht mehr willkommen
kommt mit dem Geld zurück investiert in
Russland der Westen wird euch genauso
verhandeln wie mich das heißt also ein
Aufruf zu dieser nationalen Einheit
interessant finde ich auch dass er
eigentlich überhaupt über keine
Perspektiven des Krieges gesprochen hat
das heißt wohin will er eigentlich das
Thema spart er aus das heißt auch wenn
sie sagen keine Perspektive im Krieg
auch keine exit Strategie das heißt
weitermachen bis irgendeine Entscheidung
man hat den Eindruck am halten dessen
was sie an vier Gebieten annektiert
haben
offiziell aber manche Dinge wie zum
Beispiel Regime wechseln in Kiew wird
nicht mehr ausgesprochen und zwar Nazis
aber das Ziel wird nicht mehr genannt
aber man hätte vielleicht auch erwartet
dass eine Reaktion auf den Vorstoß der
Chinesen gibt ähm Friedensinitiative was
hätte am besten gemacht wenn jetzt Putin
plötzlich die Hand ausstreckt und sagt
wir müssen Friedensverhandlungen führen
also all diejenigen die vielleicht auch
hierzulande gehofft haben Putin würde
nun also zum Diplomaten werden hat er
auch enttäuscht also jetzt die
Unterschriftensammler hierzulande kein
Signal ich habe den Eindruck es ist
letztlich ein weiter so aber ohne
irgendeine politische
endvorstellung bei Putin nicht nur
einmal in dieser rund eineinhalb Stunden
Rede hat er ja die Atomwaffen angeführt
die Atomwaffen russland hat gesagt wenn
der Westen irgendetwas macht wenn die
USA etwas machen man würde sofort
reagieren er hat auch noch mal die
Modernisierung noch mal der russischen
Streitkräfte angesprochen ziemlich am
Anfang seiner Rede und hat gesagt
die müssen weiterhin modernisiert werden
und müssen auch alle Bereiche müssen
Zugang zu Atomwaffen haben versteckte
Drohung für einen Ersteinsatz
das denke ich nicht es ist letztlich
auch die verbliebene Karte die ja nur
noch ausspülen kann das heißt er merkt
die Warnung vor den sogenannten
Superwaffen also den
hyperschallraketenüberschall Flugzeugen
die ja im letzten Jahr ausgesprochen
hatte an die glaubt keiner mehr keiner
glaubt mir sozusagen an Putins
Wunderwaffen insofern ist der Rückbezug
auf die Atomwaffen die letzte Karte wo
er sagt also vor dem müsst ihr noch
Angst haben aber er hat eigentlich wenn
man so im englischen sagt Game changer
also ein eine Waffe die wirklich das
Kriegsgeschehen ändert die hat er nicht
mehr und ich glaube wer ein halbes Jahr
dafür braucht eine Stadt wie baut
einzunehmen was ein Kleinstadt ist der
wird nicht ein Atomkrieg mit den USA
anfangen insofern ist es
Selbstversicherung nach innen natürlich
auch ein spielen sozusagen mit der
latentenangst im Westen aber die hat
deutlich abgenommen im letzten halben
Jahr das Putin zu dieser Eskalation
bereit ist weil er selbst kleine
Gewinner auf dem Schlachtfeld mit den
vorhandenen Ressourcen nicht erreichen
kann das wäre der eine Punkt seine Rede
der andere Punkt seiner Rede sie hatten
es ja auch eben gerade schon mal erwähnt
ist ja diese Rückbesinnung auf russische
Werte wir können das alleine ist steckt
aber nicht in diese selbst gewählten
Isolation und das ist es ja mittlerweile
schon steckt da nicht auch eine gewisse
Gefahr wieder noch ein Konfliktpotenzial
so nach dem Motto es sind eh alle
Brücken abgebrochen Richtung Westen auch
im wirtschaftlichen Bereich wir haben ja
nichts mehr zu verlieren
er behaupte hier nicht dass sie nichts
zu verlieren hätten sondern dass sie nur
was zu gewinnen hätten nämlich dass sie
jetzt mit den Chinesen mit den Indern
mit Südostasien Vietnam und so weiter
enger kooperieren auch subsahara Afrika
also letztlich ist das wegbrechende
einen Märkte eigentlich die Eröffnung
von neuen Märkten also insofern sieht er
den Krieg eher als eine Chance
verkauft es so natürlich Feld der dabei
furchtbar die Zahlen in Bezug auf
Inflation in Bezug auf Ja gesagt 4 bis
55 % liegt bei 12% wird das Wachstum sei
gerade mal um 2% eingebrochen also da
belügt er das eigene Publikum sozusagen
mit mit
getünchten oder an sowjetische Zeiten
erinnern den äh Statistiken auch diese
ganzen brain Dragon der Abfluss von von
Technikern von Wissenschaftlern von
IT und so weiter die also das Abziehen
auch der westlichen westlichen Kapitals
dass man letztlich zu einer Art von so
wird Ökonom zurückkehrt wo eigentlich
eine doppelwirtschaft entsteht das heißt
jeder von den Unternehmen versucht
irgendwie an Ressourcen ranzukommen auf
krummen Wegen hinterrücks
sanktionsumgehung das heißt da werden ja
alte Muster sozusagen der doppelökonomie
wiederbelebt die eigentlich seit Anfang
der 90er Jahre in Russland nicht mehr
existierten all das verschweigte hörte
sich auch so ein bisschen so an er hat
ja immer während seiner gesamten Rede
vor allen Dingen dann im zweiten Teil wo
es ums innenpolitisch ums
wirtschaftliche gegen hat er ja auch
immer Arbeitsaufträge verteilt an das
Parlament an beispielsweise den
Ministerrat oder auch an die Gouverneure
trotzdem noch mal die Frage kann
Russland das trotzdem eventuell schaffen
ohne den Westen ohne die
wirtschaftlichen Verpflichtungen sich da
gestärkt möglicherweise so wie Putin das
gibt's hier hat
herauszuwenden im Wasser des Wortes
also wenn man sich die Zeit seit der
Auflösung der Sowjetunion seit 1991
anguckt da sind über 30 Jahre vergangen
man fragt sich warum soll er jetzt
eigentlich das Geschehen was in den
letzten 30 Jahren und schon in den über
20 Jahren von Putin und medwedis
Herrschaft nicht geschehen ist das heißt
diese Reden über die Modernisierung den
Ausbau der Infrastruktur über eine Art
von
Seidenstraße Initiative also das ist
eine Art von Anspielung auf das was die
Chinesen machen auch in der Rede von
Putin all das wird im Putins reden seit
23 Jahren wiederholt und ich habe mir
die Gesichter angeguckt auch von den
Dingen die da im Publikum saßen das hat
so ein bisschen was von den
Siegesmeldungen unterbrechen an sich
entweder gibt es Gründe warum das im
letzten 23 Jahren auch in an der
Bürokratie an der Korruption gescheiter
gibt und ist und die werden analysiert
oder ist es nur derselbe sondern hurra
Patriotismus aus eigener Kraft
und Russland durch Autarkie diese
Ressourcen Abhängigkeit also das Ende
von diesem
pietro-staatsmodell meines Erachtens
nicht schaffen und meines Erachtens muss
man sich auch vergegenwärtigen wir haben
in Deutschland diesen riesigen
braindring in den 30er Jahren gehabt das
hat fast 60 Jahre gedauert bis wir uns
davon wieder erholt hatten nach dem
Krieg das mein großes Interesse dasselbe
Problem auch haben das heißt das hat
enorme Auswirkungen darauf was man an
wissenschaftlich technologischen
Potenzial hat das wegbricht und das
lässt sich nicht mit wir sind die
stärksten und sich irgendwie auf die
Brust schlagen lässt sich das nicht
kompensieren nur noch mal kurz
nachgefragt zum Thema da waren wir ja
eben schon mal Sanktionen
es gibt ja in Deutschland auch und in
Europa aber auch in Deutschland durchaus
die Meinung diese Sanktionen Schaden uns
mehr selbst als beispielsweise Russland
das wird ja von ganz links und ganz
rechts gerne ab und an mal behauptet ist
das so also ist ein riesige Industrie
entstanden zur Umgehung der Sanktionen
ja und natürlich schaden sie uns selber
auch und Russland hat durch
Preissteigerungen im letzten Jahr oder
dadurch dass sie jetzt zum Teil auch Gas
über Indien dann wiederum an europäische
Länder verkaufen haben Sie natürlich
auch sozusagen kompensieren können aber
man muss sehen die Sanktionen wirken
durchaus und manche haben auch nicht den
Effekt schon im ersten Jahr gehabt
sondern die haben eine langfristige
Wirkung zu behaupten wir hätten damit
uns nur selbst geschädigt und Russland
überhaupt nicht das trifft überhaupt
nichts zu man muss nur den
Wirtschaftsteil der Zeitung oder vom
economes lesen dann sieht man die
Wirkung waren vielleicht nicht so
schnell da wie manche das sozusagen
sofort erwartet haben aber die Prognosen
sind relativ eindeutig Andreas erstmal
so weit vielen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung bis hierhin